olá pessoal aqui quem fala é o dark diz
muito bem vindos a mais velha e
mostrámos aqui um vídeo muito especial
como a responder pelo tempo hoje vou
enfrentar a minha namorada é porque não
sabe tem uma namorada que catarina sinte
pi ou limpar em baixo e ela brincar casa
e eu fingi que estava editar um vídeo
pra hoje então ela aproveitou a falta
deles comprou vídeo dela vamos fazer
aqui em casa e claro o movimento não
estava editar vídeo nenhum porque eu
quis que ela foi sozinha as compras para
aproveitar este momento não é bom só o
que vai acontecer aqui basicamente eu
vou tentar evitar a catarina mas o que
acontece é que ela não se dá se então
faça um membro eu vou ter que ter um
corte mesmo muita cor e eu vou tentar de
tudo de tudo para conseguir evitar mas
alguma coisa alguma coisa que o meu
trunfo e astron é parte toda a maquiagem
dela tudo parte tudo com um martelo eu
sei que ela não vai evitar eu posso
sentir à vontade ela não vai evitar mas
condenou por ter toda a maquiagem dela é
isso sim é e ela vai evitar desvios até
mas claro ela vai ficar muito triste eu
tenho certeza
portanto eu já comprei algumas coisinhas
para repor o que o partido vai saber o
que é complexo logo conquista pelo sul é
muito fofinho muito ruim e ela vai durar
eu tenho certeza e também comprei uma
flor neto que toda mulher gosta de
florinda afirma catarina agora uma
florzinha rosa também mais coisas eu
comprei química maquiagem porque eu vou
eu vou destruir tudo o que ela tem a lei
vamos entrar elas invadem sempre a nossa
casa vai sempre ela tem alguma coisa que
ela adora mesmo tipo essa coisa aqui que
é uma maquiagem terá peso bastante
destaque para os olhos ou qualquer coisa
assim somos sombra estranho e eu sei que
ela adora esta palestra é isso ou eu vou
focar muita destruição nesta paleta mas
atenção eu comprei umas coisas que eu
acho que ela vai estar com o tempo vamos
acreditar e lightning gripe ao ano
foi lá e não respondia que apesar da
maquiagem básica mas os lápis nos olhos
e batom eu gosto de jogar todos os
batons dela do kutato eu vou escrever
nos pergunta de estudos de caso o ato em
que comprei aqui também que é um projeto
mas planos que pagar mas claro pessoal
está catarina por isso não pode ficar
por aqui sem comprar mais coisas nem
porque eu sei que vou enfrentar
então eu também comprei brinquedos
porque ela adora brinquedos eu comprei
aqui um brinquedo maio em são paulo
porque ela adora esta série com break
mais figurinhas também para aí muitas
figurinhas do my little pony e
compreende também os outros sua lógica é
suficiente não quer fazer já só eu não
saí mais que suficiente acho que ela vai
ficar feliz com isso e agora é só
esperar que ela chega a cair mais pelas
horas eu acho que ela deve demorar ainda
maior aos 35 minutos eu acho então é
agora só pra qualquer pessoa mas pelas
gafes
[Música]
um vídeo em baixo
olha não estou aqui a gente vai jogar no
furacão
o jogo simples não é meu é meu
a oea morro do boi para ler de memória
tirar essa placa final 1 já para não
falar nada não voltem evitar eu estou te
irritar não fui eu uso para a forum do
amanhã
não não
dentro desta lógica eu vá
o pessoal da minha nova luta muito mas
muito jogar a culpa em pé perto da minha
roupa
agora os batons meu amor eu adoro button
por meio do meu amor
adoro o pessoal do meu novo look
button agora maquiagem adora
não o clube
[Aplausos]
adoro mas fala agora mas a pessoa não
fica pronto subiu para lavar a roupa
suja toda vamos ter que batalhar muito
grande ainda não é conhecida
eu mantive aqui mais presentinhos menina
e neca um sol esta é parte em que diz
que eu ia recuperar a minha menina mas
se a gente nem fala mais uma paleta do
vinho e discuta o caso
mas mais do que isso eu não acredito que
não sabe meu amor eu sair eu sei que
gosto morte de sua mãe não não não não
muitas coisas nunca são paulo nunca
[Música]
saber basta base da cara é o cara como é
que eu não tenho visto como é que o
ribeiro 21 dias 300 milagres neste vídeo
a apoiarem o canal para o pessoal que
não vai ter uma série
daí não é uma série de som um vídeo eu
não sei que vocês deixem quem é dos
milagres ou seja está em milagres
eu vou tentar me lembrar que só eu